decapitated nuns my ex-girlfriend and
vampire babies yes the BBC's latest
adaptation of Dracula really sucks
okay I'll delete my channel now no it
doesn't suck but I still can't get over
the fact Dracula is able to use tinder
when he can't even take a photo of
himself in this video we're gonna take a
deep dive into Dracula's ending its
relationship with the original Bram
Stoker novel and some of its more
mysterious unanswered questions so grab
a nice glass of wine because here we go
the final episode of this three-part
miniseries begins back in Hungary in
1897 coincidentally the same year the
Brom Stoker novel Dracula of which it's
based came out this is a flashback to
the end of episode 1 where Dracula has
gained access to st. Mary's convent to
hunt down and kill sister Agatha van
Helsing a woman obsessed with stopping
Dracula and his dark power in the novel
this character is a dutch doctor by the
name of Abraham Van Helsing and has
commonly been referred to as a vampire
hunter the name van Helsing has spawned
several film and TV adaptations which
usually surrounds someone from the van
Helsing family taking on vampires and
other monsters sister Agatha stands
alongside Mina Murray the fiancee of
Jonathan Harker this beautiful chap who
was the focus of episode 1 Agatha pleads
for her safety in return offering up
herself to Dracula an offer he accepts
deposit
you know travel to the new world it's no
wonder the episode begins with this
flashback considering the two decisions
Dracula makes here will eventually lead
to his downfall
letting Mena go allows her to travel
back to England and start the Jonathan
Harker Foundation with the money
inherited to her by her rich father the
Jonathan Harker foundation named after
her late fiance had a secret agenda to
find Dracula and perform research on him
the second decision to drink from agatha
turning her into an undead would cast
ripples throughout the next century as
we'll find out 123 years later a great
descendent of the van Helsing family dr.
Zoe van Helsing has made it her mission
to stop Dracula something she wouldn't
have been able to do as I'll get into
later if Dracula had never sucked her
granddad's blood in the first place fast
forward to the year 2020 this is where
we left off in episode 2 as we find out
later Dracula was able to escape
imprisonment and evade the Harker
foundation by dispersing into a pile of
bats later breaking into a store to
steal some fresh threads and hiding in a
local home a home whose owner he
conveniently stuffed in a fridge in case
he wants leftovers having spent the last
century at the bottom of the ocean
Dracula takes a moment to marvel how
normal people today live better than
kings and queens of the past he's also
able to see the Sun through the
television or as he calls it the moving
picture box
Dracula's obsession with the Sun is
something we see in Episode one he
brings a dying Jonathan Harker to the
roof of the castle as the Sun rises
wanting him to describe it to him as
we'll find out at the very end however
Dracula isn't susceptible to the Sun as
we were left to believe but we'll get
into that in a bit in the mirror we see
Dracula's true form
he's now five hundred years old having
lived by sustaining himself through the
blood of others you see the thing that
intrigues sister Agatha about Dracula is
unlike the other undead he's managed to
live with his intellect and body fairly
intact she goes on to tell Harker in
Episode one that there's a contagion in
the world most who get inflicted with
this disease become shells of their
former selves slowly devolving into
rotting pieces of flesh trapped within
their own bodies uncontrol
these are the zombie like creatures
Johnny finds in the crypts of Dracula's
castle dracula however has been able to
stave off the side effects agatha
surmises this is partly because he is
particularly feasts on preferring
intellectuals and aristocrats so he can
gain their knowledge by drinking one's
blood dracula is able to gain that
person's memories as he says to John
Harker in Episode one love life this is
how Dracula is able to figure out the
name of John's fiancee as well as how
technology works in 2020 by drinking
Bob's blood
aka fridge man he's able to know most of
how things operate in the current year
Dracula's respite is short-lived when
dr. Zoe van Helsing tracks him down he's
essentially trapped since it's daytime
and he can't go out into the sunlight
she sends him a coffin filled with
Transylvanian soil for him to get into
as Bram Stoker outlined in his novel a
vampire can only rest in soil from the
land of its origins it can't survive
without it but before he gets inside he
wants to chat with dr. van Helsing she
agrees knowing if he makes a wrong move
the house will be demolished and he'll
die from the sunlight
Dracula however has other plans he
decides to take a bite of Zoe but vomits
up her blood not knowing that her blood
is infected with cancer what if the
dying is death to the vampire it's here
that Dracula is finally captured by the
foundation we're then introduced to a
cast of new characters including Jack
Seward Quincey and Lucy Westenra all of
whom appear in the Stoker novel although
in the novel Jack's name is John but
they likely changed it so it wouldn't
get confused with the other John
character John Harker Jack gets a call
from Jonathan Harker and see how it
could get confusing leading us to
believe the main character from episode
1 is still alive however the rest of the
ID is cut off and it's actually a call
from the John Harker Foundation where he
used to be a test subject you see dr.
Zoe used to be Jack's teacher and
offered him this job since it pays very
well and would help him get through
college with Dracula back in the picture
the foundation will need all sorts of
blood for their tests at first Jack
ignores the calls but when he sees the
love of his life Lucy accept a proposal
from douchebag Quincey he decides to
head back to the foundation at the
Foundation Dracula is housed in a vault
where their current sunrise and sunset
are held on display Jack arrives and is
told about Dracula's discovery how
divers found him in a quote restorative
coma if you recall from episode 2 Agatha
and the sea captain blew up the ship
Demeter in an attempt to stop Dracula
from arriving in England but he survived
by enclosing himself in this coffin
later when he bites one of the divers he
regains consciousness landing ashore
sometime later Dracula is held within
this very expensive cell looking like it
was designed for a Hannibal Lecter or
some Bond villain here Zoe can beam
sunlight into the cell in order to hold
back Dracula's advances she's come to
take his blood blood which will become
integral in bringing dracula down for
good we find the truth it's also here
where I had to roll my eyes on how
Dracula was able to get Wi-Fi on his
iPad and not only that use it to Skype
with a lawyer I know they said they gave
it to him so he could read books but why
not just give him regular paperbacks and
why does this room even have Wi-Fi in it
moving on so the lawyer Frank arrives
who is played by the show's co-creator
Mark Gatiss who also worked on Sherlock
and Doctor Who rank worked for Hawkins
and Wentworth the same law firm Jonathan
Harker worked for and the one that sent
him to Transylvania in the first place
Frank argues Dracula can't be kept here
against his will and thus must be
released this bird Zoe to do something
drastic
drink Dracula's blood which has the side
effect of being able to transfer her
great aunts memories through her DNA
we're transported three months in the
future and Dracula takes Lucy on the
best tinder date of all time to a local
graveyard in the novel Lucy is best
friends with Mina Murray and after Lucy
begins to show strange symptoms it's dr.
van Helsing who suspects it's Dracula's
doing this version is a bit different
after all that Brom Stoker could have
predicted the horrors of tinder in the
1890s I'd be very impressed Lucy and
Dracula have a strange relationship
according to Dracula she's the only one
in 500 years who willingly gave herself
up to him she's addicted to that
dreamlike state she puts him in while
she's being bitten among Dracula's many
powers is the ability to lull his bite
victims into a false state of dream kind
of like how Jonathan
Harken would dream of his fiancee even
though he was being bitten
speaking of lawyers Frank does a
crossword which is just Dracula written
all over again kind of like how when
agatha shows John his letters they're
like something out of The Shining where
he writes how he's gonna serve Dracula
over and over again
Frank is under this same type of spell
Lucy succumbs to Dracula's power and is
sent to be cremated but unbeknownst to
everyone else she's Undead later
returning as a burnt corpse but it's
only when Zoe is visited by Agatha
through some DNA dreamlike state that
she asked Jake to take her from the
hospital to visit Dracula there's even a
few hints that she is controlled by
Agatha at this point like when we see
Agatha's reflection in the mirror or
after she says something odd and Dracula
remarks dr. houseing you don't sound
quite yourself with Jack and Zoe at
Dracula's Lucy arrives calling yourself
the bloofer lady which kind of sounds
like it could be naughty but it's not
it's believed that the term blufor is
derive from the cockney accents of the
abducted children from the novel which
translates to beautiful
I could try attempting it but it would
sound something like folk look that's
bad Lucy is obsessed with being
beautiful pretty and married so it's
ironic that she becomes ugly burnt and a
bride of Dracula's Jack in an act of
mercy stabs Lucy with a steak
disintegrating her into ash which i
think is a bit weird since the undead
lady from episode one didn't
disintegrate when she was stabbed in the
heart
so whatever Zoe asked Jack to leave
which she says is for Dracula's own good
but I think it's really because she
knows she needs to sacrifice herself in
order for Dracula to be killed once and
for all with Zoe and Dracula alone she
rips the curtains off exposing Dracula
to daylight but he survives he's not
affected by sunlight at all and Zoe
knows it everything Dracula had been
afraid of they cross the sunlight going
into homes without being invited were
simply habits he had picked up over the
years and believed to be true Zoe needs
to expose this to get at the root of
what Dracula is really afraid of death
everyone in Dracula's family died a
courageous ro of death on the
battlefield while he sculpt about in the
shadows of the castle he became afraid
of death and ironically fell in love
with
girl who didn't fear death at all Lucy
that's what made her so attractive to
him and why he fed on her over and over
his fear of the cross stems from the
fact it represents the courage he longs
to possess the courage it takes to die
Zoe is the antithesis of Dracula ready
to die in the face of the cancer that
has taken over her body the only way to
conquer death she says is to face it
without fear until Dracula is dead she
says to him we live forever
with this realization Dracula approaches
the window in one of my favorite shots
of the entire series his body wrapped in
sunlight with the shadow of the Cross
reflecting onto it two things that he
lived in fear of he's now embracing the
only thing left is death as the screen
fades to white we transition to the
Streamlight state of him making love to
Agatha but in reality he's drinking
Agatha's poisonous blood he knows that
it will kill him and in the process also
kill her he has embraced death and let
go of fear walking away from an eternal
life of shame the final shot is of these
two arch-nemesis together as one in bed
as we fade to a picture of the Sun the
thing he once feared but now calls
beautiful Dracula may not be the most
original interpretation of the Brahm
Stoker novel but overall I found it to
be a fun cat-and-mouse game between
sister Agatha and Dracula but I want to
hear what you thought of the show below
make sure to give the video a like and
subscribe as 20:20 will be filled with
new episode breakdowns and they explain
videos and tons of other surprises until
next time remember love life